as you can see here i have been pretty
packed up and ready to go um
and
like i kind of pack and unpack like
every couple of weeks
um right now i was supposed to leave
this morning
and get on a flight this afternoon but i
didn't
so now i want to work out i gotta find
my clothes
[Music]
oh here we go right on top
recently i have had like four different
tickets i guess to get out of here for
may 10
and then some roots
going from like shanghai beijing
trying to get
to la so i think i i counted it up and
it's like roughly you know eight or nine
tickets all together
[Music]
um i think that there is like
still kind of like this we're open
but you can't leave from there
maybe some kind of like double speak or
something that's going on um you know
they they are saying that they're open
but actually
most of the passenger planes cannot
leave there here's all my cancelled
flights my bookings that i've confirmed
and then of course like you know the
flights
um cancel refund
and
you know
just trying to figure out how to how to
move
so that maybe i can leave some time
before
i die
so all of the flights that i haven't
been able to make
have been cancelled um by the airlines
themselves and they always like send me
this message like your flight has been
canceled due to public safety concerns
and so i think it's a the government is
actually telling them like you can't
take off this you know not going to
happen
we had missed so much time
where we couldn't go outside and i just
started kind of feeling
a bit sad that have been so long since
we had been outside and just also i felt
quite sad that we were all so happy that
we had this very
limited amount of freedom um and it just
yeah was quite bittersweet to sort of
just have that realization of like we
can go outside but
most people can go outside like even
people in prison have yard time no i
think that uh yeah we'll leave for good
um i'm going to go to california so um
i think that
you know with there's a lot of people
um
you know chinese americans there i can
still use my chinese it'll come in handy
and everything like that but
um yeah yeah i think
i don't think i will leave the united
states for quite a long time after i get
back to be honest
[Music]
i'm on the final league of my journey
here and i just wanted to say a quick
goodbye to everyone in china there's a
lot of really lovely people here
um and i hope that you guys survive
these lockdowns with as little pain as
possible and these logistics get a lot
better for everybody to make them more
humane thanks guys bye
[Music]